favorite Rambo this is a this is two
player as well so this is a first-person
shooter that's comment on them plays yes
it is you're going to play as the blue
man go ad that's comment on xbox 360
playstation 3 and pc / steam and it
chronicles the life of John Jay Rambo
yeah what is the J stand for okay John
John John Rambo yes name I think it's
james actually at which is a its its
first blood first blood part two and
three all turn into a video game and I
always so I've got my own reticle yeah
yeah cuz it's an unreal shooter is yeah
and because obviously we've got this one
gun but there's the two of us shooting
because that's what happened in Vietnam
I don't know you weren't there man you
don't know at we can also i'm taking
cover here see that i'm watching you
yeah so you can't you can't decide if
we're taking cover is that is the issue
I'm gonna play with you for a lil bit
here and we're gonna swap over in let
you play play what yourself is it work I
will play am though this is yeah but
this is a pretty I don't know this kind
of came out of nowhere we gave a six at
10 on gamespot com have you played any
Rambo games in the past I feel like it's
like Terminator and Robocop and there's
been about 20 releases of both games but
no one's ever played any of them I
played the original one of the NES which
is not good at all okay it's a very bad
confusing game so you're saying this is
in keeping with the launch it might be
but round before they're gonna be better
but that's not singapore i just realize
it's got an active reload thing see that
geez yeah it's where is it how do you
feel Oh what's the X I mean how do you
reload if you will not have you only
fired one per clip since we started
doing all I got if you hold down our the
art our button there you go I'll do it
too what's that do let's shoot let me
loads okay not trigger but Dominic
I feel like steam has become the my
go-to place for playing local
multiplayer video games gothic an
absolute worst place to crash with like
nidhogg and samurai samurai gone and
they're in Rambo here we clearly have a
another game you can add into that mix
so weird what's your favorite on-rails
shooter it's good question hail to heal
later house a dead is great were you
playing those games passive dead yeah
House of the House of the Dead I guess
typing of the dead I played a lot of ya
in your career abs no I never it was the
rock a bird in Japan and wheezed horses
I you think Ireland got the tithing of
the day arcade game I think that's since
coming on Good Old Games calm timing of
the Dead yes I'm honest team oh it is on
steam yeah as you wants the sequel
typing of the dead overkill which is
takes house the dead overkill and turns
it into typing of the dead base okay for
those who don't know typing of the Dead
was essentially a on-rails shooter but
instead of shooting the screen you would
type Edwards and that would pop up there
are some really strange words in their
20 for bosses they'd have stuff like
mary had a little lamb whose fleece was
white as snow you have to like to type
in like I I remember thinking at the
time it's rain when Mavis Beacon typing
tutor reserves to him all this typing
tutor prod I mean I we were that in
school they're not like a product they
had a I remember this came at typing in
the commander in the same time and they
actually had like commercials saying
novice beacon we're gonna come eat you
or something zombies gonna murder your
face unless you buy Man 2 speaking but I
just like the idea of this really small
no one lesson by typing the dead so I
like idiot of this really small sub
genre video games and no one ever cared
about alright here's John we have to
look at the Rambo skin this is yeah this
life alone Adrian so shiny I love that
scene in Rambo where and he wins the
boxing fight yeah any yells for his wife
yeah yeah and he beats up all the meat
oh we're dead Peter brand I'm gonna let
you play this single player oh thank you
and while I take questions from the chat
if you have any questions at all for
Peter but Rambo the video game please
send them in either via the twitch chat
or in the comments and I'm actually got
some quite
shins about John Rambo today I want to
ask you myself why do you played this
video games yeah i'll see if i can
answer them truthfully and before that
actually i want to remind the folks at
home that we are giving away copies of
south park and the stick of truth on the
platform of your choice can I bucket it
is are you like it no I got this second
X know you got though if you want to
women it always follow us at gamespot on
twitter use the hashtag GS the lobby and
make sure you are following us so we can
contact you find out what version of the
game you want a perkin you want to get
as well yeah we don't have we don't have
boo we don't have extra chapters of
Rambo the video game Peter you just
gotta go play regular eyes version go
for it we haven't beaten any of the
missions that's not course not honestly
I could see ya ya yer to that controller
oh you got rid of that one what's the
main one big alright perfect and when
the Rambo come out Peter question 1 1984
no came in 2014 this video game came out
in 2014 bitter alright I didn't give
that one did not get that one right when
did the Rambo when the Rambo first blood
the video the the movie come out Peter
2014 no that's 1982 gosh you're close
though okay what is Rambo's first name
Jeremiah oh it's it's a jonathan be
honest john you're right read it sure is
John should we ask john travolta watch
rambo first name is I've special Jordan
I've spent all this morning John
Travolta izing 4 equals names obviously
for work yeah what else would we be
prepared the lobby all we have to do is
wait for Vince on pellet internal and in
these days he days back there oh yeah
I'm ink so it's either ladder a creeper
I thought yeah and maybe a little bit of
all alright someone in the check and
control defies his name that'll be
that'll be pretty good Jennifer BL is
Jennifer boars horse I love John
Travolta someone
I got another question for you where was
the Rambo first blood set the movie and
or the first level of video game what
Scott's first level I mean vena ya
Vietnam brigid hope Washington it was
impotent hope Washington and you
remember what was it that killed John
Rambo's is his soldier friends I don't
know what kindness no no I got uh some
sort of bullet it was Agent Orange oh
man Agent Orange can you tell that i
haven't watched this movie in years i
want you to give a rating of that and
we've already reviewed round by the
video game i want you to give a rating
out of 10 around by the video game right
now on the show right now yeah mmm at a
chance five unofficial gamespot room I
don't want duck how do I behind press
down cuz down yeah amazing thought all
right that's it that's about as much
Rambo the video game I could take right
now Peter Brown it is if we've got to
get to sell park and talk to Vince I
thought about titanfall and what not to
do